i'm trying to figure out this whole
trolling thing
because i think it's really destructive
i've been
the outrage mob the outrage mobs the
just the
the dynamics of twitter has been really
bothering me
okay and i've been trying to figure out
if we
can try to build an alternative to
twitter perhaps or try to encourage
twitter to be better
how to have nuanced healthy
conversations
like the reason i talk about love isn't
just for the love's sake
it's just a good base from which to have
difficult conversations like that's a
good starting point
because if you start like i would argue
that
the kind of conversation you have on
twitter is fun
but it might not be a good starting
point for a difficult nuanced
conversation
well i'm not interested in having those
conversations with most people
no i know but so i agree with you your
point is valid yes
but like i'm saying so if we were trying
to have
a difficult nuanced conversation about
say
race in america or policing is there
racism institutional racism of policing
okay there's uh the only conversations
that have been nuanced about it that
i've heard
is in the podcasting medium which is the
magic of podcasting which is great
but that that's the downside of
podcasting
is it's a very small number of people
even if it's in the thousands it's still
small
and then there's millions of people on
social media and
they're not having nuanced conversation
at all they're not capable of it that's
the difference in you that's saved their
minds i believe they are so that's
there's
no data and then both of us aren't being
not scientific
you don't have data to support your
world either you're making the claim
well you are too no i'm not if i'm
looking at an object
the free the
your claim is that people are
fundamentally stupid aren't you a
martial artist
yes how does it feel
i know
[Laughter]
you really don't think people are deep
down like
capable of being intelligent no not at
all
not not deep down not surface i'm not
joking i'm not being tongue-in-cheek and
not being cynical i do not at all
at all think they have this capacity i'm
gonna think
because you're being so clear about it
you're not even
i'm gonna hear yourself you know why
here's here's a
here's evidence for my position not
proof and this is of course data that is
of little use but it's of interest
a lot of times when you have an audience
as big as mine and people come at you
not only will people say the same thing
the same concept they'll say the same
concept in the same way
that is not a mind yeah that's surface
evidence
um you're saying this iceberg looks like
this from the surface
yeah i'm saying there's an iceberg there
that if
challenged can um
can rise to the occasion of deep
thinking
and you're saying nope nope it's just
frozen water
isn't that the russian expression uh
that's ice cream
no not marouane
like no one's there actually i don't
know yeah it means like yeah
yeah it's like thought it means
okay well uh so you're challenging me to
be a little
bit more rigorous i think i'll try i'm
not challenge you anything i'm just
saying no not challenging me but like
i'm challenging myself based on what
you're saying because i'd like to prove
you wrong
and find actual yeah data to just show
you wrong and i think i can but
i would need to uh get that data that's
funny you said i think i can when when
they were working on my biography ego
and hubris
the title i had suggested was the little
engine that could but
they shouldn't like it i think that's a
great title it's pretty good yeah
you